the guilt of feeling grateful to be
alive is heavy wanting to smile about
surviving but not sure the people around
you already as the world mourns the
victims killed and viciously slain I
feel guilty about screaming about my
legs and pain because I could feel
nothing like the other 49 who weren't so
lucky to feel this pain of mine I never
thought in a million years that this
could happen I never thought in a
million years that my eyes could witness
something so tragic
looking at the souls leaving the bodies
of individuals looking at the killer's
machine gun throughout my right
peripheral looking at the blood and
debris covered on everyone's faces
looking at the gunman's feet under the
star as he paces the guilt of feeling
lucky to be alive as heavy it's like the
weight of the oceans wall is crushing
uncontrolled by levees it's like being
drugged through the grass with a
shattered leg and thrown on the back of
a Chevy it's like being rushed to the
hospital and told you're going to make
it when you laid beside individuals who
lies are brutally taking the guilt of
being alive
is him
you